you've got to speak up this thing about
dropping our voice you know i used to go
into movie studios for meetings
and i'd be sitting out in the waiting
room you know you sit for a few minutes
before they call you in and
almost every time somebody would come up
to me and drop his voice and say i i saw
you on hannity i i saw you on back and i
would always say the same thing why are
you whispering you're in the right
hand
and i understand the fear and i
understand you know we we famously had
this uh supposedly secret organization
the friends of abe out in hollywood
and i kept saying to the leaders you
know we've got to go public and they
wouldn't do it because they didn't want
the working guys to get caught the
gaffers and the guys who were not movie
stars and all this but i just thought if
you don't if you if you act in secret
then you look like you're ashamed and if
you act in secret you look like you're
afraid
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
prolific screenwriter a host at the
daily wire
a multi-time author and author of the
brand new book when christmas comes
andrew clavin welcome back to the reuben
report
good to see you dave how are you i am
just fine i feel that we have to just
get some stuff out of the way right up
top though because last
i saw you was here at my house i had a
dinner party right before you made your
exodus and and left california left los
angeles and it was a wonderful evening
michael knowles several other you know
far right figures and uh we were going
around the table
and you wanted whiskey and i said no no
i want you to try this tequila
and you said no no i like whiskey and i
demanded that you try the tequila
and then an hour later you admitted to
me you just didn't like the tequila and
i i've been sitting on this for like six
months i feel bad about this you know
what i mean it was your going away thing
sure you abandoned me here
but i made you drink tequila and i feel
bad you're a whiskey guy
you know it's i'm a creature of habit
what can i tell you i discovered mcallen
12 many years ago and the guy at the
store i lived in england and every week
i go and the guys say you have to try
something else and i try something else
i think yeah i really like that mcallen
12 and i go back the next week and say
you got to try something else that went
on for about three months and finally i
said you know mccallum 12 is the best
and the guy said yeah you're right
i thought if i you know i like it i
stick with it you conservatives you love
whiskey now i know i'm the new guy here
i would consider myself sort of a new
school conservative but i bring tequila
in it freaks people out you guys it's
all about whiskey for you people yeah
the tequila is just a little edgy for us
you know i mean whiskey you know we know
where you're going with whiskey you're
going straight down the tubes
great time and it goes well with steak
which we're also very big on steak steak
and cigars and whiskey are really
perfect yes you are all men it's very
obvious you're mad yeah that's it doing
your thing
all right so you did leave me here
you've been gone for what about six
months now life is good for you you're
happy you've you've left and nothing
good is happening here fair to say
fair to say i turned virginia i
single-handedly turned virginia red uh i
could i moved when i moved to virginia
and because it's kind of between the
daily wire and my uh publishing life in
new york and you know within months i
just managed to i'm spartacus i just
said you know all right follow me
everybody we're gonna turn this state
and they rushed into the voting booth
and now we're a red state so for real
what was it like for those couple weeks
before the election and then that night
i mean it was really i think a huge
moment if we're going to get any wins i
think that was the one that we needed i
had been saying it for weeks that's the
one keep an eye on this one and it
actually happened and i think a lot of
people have hope now
well you know it's it's interesting when
i got to uh virginia i live in northern
virginia which is the liberal the blue
part of virginia and several people said
to me oh boy this is a really liberal
place it's really left wing and i was
looking around and having come from los
angeles i was thinking that you know not
really so much it's not the same thing a
lot of military people a lot of people
who are democrats in the old kind of
sense of the word that yes they want a
welfare state or some kind of you know
normal thing that two people might argue
about and around the 50-yard line as
they used to say but it was not that
crazy
uh l.a thing where the any idea that
comes out oh yeah men are women now okay
that but that's good you know everybody
hey
we're racist everyone's racist though so
we got to teach children to be racist
yeah good idea this was this is like a
normal american state with with
democrats and republicans in it and when
they found out oh you know we're
teaching your children that it's okay to
be a pedophile or actually the the the
object of pedophilia it's okay to you
know to hate people because they're
white or the black people are like i'm
sorry what you know where did that come
from where in la people just go like
lemmings off the cliff in virginia not
so much so it was very it was very tense
i thought it should have been 80 to 20
percent it was only two or three
percentage points and to be honest with
you i was worried about the kind of
trump contingent you know i'm good
friends with sebastian gorka who just
loves donald trump and he was picking on
younkin and i'm saying to him you know
it's a purple state you know we're not
going to get everything we want but
junkin was a talented guy and because of
trump i think because of trump he
understood that he had to fight the
culture war that you know you don't
fight you don't fight the culture where
you you can't win you don't fight over
abortion you don't fight over you know
marriage you fight but to fight teaching
racism in school yeah you can do that
and so i think that donald trump taught
him something but he managed to excite
the trump contingent without linking
himself uh to donald trump in fact there
was one hilarious story that when trump
troll that he is said he was coming to
virginia uh junkins people called him up
and said no no
virginia so he he really found the right
note as we didn't in the recall in
california and and that's exciting
because it means you know
ronald reagan said basically and there's
a paraphrase but he said republicans
fail when they turn out not to be who
they said they were
democrats fail when they turn out to be
who they say they are and when they they
go too far all the time and so
right this minute when democrats are
being everything they say and they're
ruining everything everything they touch
goes bad this is a good moment it's a
good moment to remind people that a
little bit of common sense a little bit
of good business a little bit of family
life you know not such a bad thing and
you can build a very nice country and a
very nice life off that wait are you
saying that the people on msnbc who told
me that it was all because of those
middle america white supremacist women
that's what they were saying it's all
the women who are always voting in white
supremacists
are you saying that
joy reid is not telling me the truth
i mean we got this lieutenant governor
who's a gun-toting black lady who was in
the marines and it's like and everybody
this is the thing everybody loves her
and they're telling us oh yeah but she
is white supremacy this is the mark of
white supremacy when you vote for a
black person who doesn't agree with us
yeah and so you know at some point you
just got to hope that there's enough
common sense
and courage in the american people where
they stand up to that because it's not
just common sense a lot of people i know
including democrats are saying to me you
know this woke stuff is bad there's
something wrong with this but you also
have to have courage because they will
throw you off twitter they will throw
you off facebook they might get you
fired from your job they might get you
canceled so you've got to have the
courage to say you know out loud
we don't want this and what they did in
virginia was they attack people's kids
and that will turn a lot of moms and a
lot of dads into very brave people uh
you know that you get the mama and papa
bears will just rip your head off before
they let you ruin their kids so as a guy
that spent i think you spent a couple
decades here in crazy la right how long
were you here for well i was only in la
for seven years but i was in before that
i was in santa barbara for 15 years so
all in all i got the california
experience for two decades so as a guy
that was around that and also was around
hollywood and and you know doing movies
and clint eastwood although he's one of
the few sane ones we've got but yeah but
you've been around the machine
what is it have you like been able to
really unpack maybe now that you've
stepped away from it like what is it
that causes that group think amongst
these people who so often seemingly vote
against their own interests they cannot
be happy that the homeless people are
now climbing up the hollywood hills like
we're in walking dead
no it is absolutely true but you know
there's certain things there's certainly
breaks walls between them for instance
in san francisco the rich people are
living in uh silicon valley you know the
rich people are not living in the places
that they let go down the drain there is
you know it's a funny thing because in a
way in a way it's a point that marx karl
marx himself might have made you know
karl marx
basically believed that your wages had
not gone you hadn't become richer if
there was now a bigger divide between
you
uh and the really rich people he
believed it was all relative you know so
even though you were doing better if the
next guy was doing 10 times better you
were going to be unhappy and there's a
lot of human truth to that i mean that's
you know it's envy it's coveted
covetousness those are just human traits
and so we have got a moment now when
some of these wealthy people are so
wealthy and so detached and so
surrounded by other people like
themselves and so
uh disdainful of the ordinary men and
women who just want to do their jobs and
and have some fun and you know get
married and have kids they're so
disdainful of that life that they really
have no idea what people are talking
about some of these people who are
accusing
look i i lived out of the country for
seven years this is the least racist
country on earth it is the least racist
country on earth and when they talk
about systemic racism it's the least
systemic racist country on earth because
obviously they're always going to be
racist people but
they don't know it they don't know it
when they talk about oh yeah these
people are just racist they believe it
because they never see them they never
meet them they never talk to them they
never listen to them some of the stuff
that you and i talk about
on what is now called conservative uh
media they've never heard they have
never heard it and when they discover it
they're absolutely shocked i mean
russell brand the comedian yeah he was a
very very bright guy but he is kind of
left to center
when he found out that the russian
collusion thing was a hoax he went on
the air and he said i'm gobsmacked i'm
flabbergasted who knew well we knew you
know we knew and we said it all the time
and a lot of stuff that we know
ultimately becomes mainstream but they
never stop and say oh gee
the right wingers were telling the truth
and the new york times and cnn and nbc
were all lying they just never say that
think of all the people that they made
into idols andrew cuomo uh you know uh
what was the other guys michael avenatti
you know is that was that his name yeah
yeah uh and and now dr fauci uh you know
torturing dogs having eating the faces
of dogs literally like you cannot make
this stuff up eating the faces off dogs
that they don't let their paws go i mean
it's just insane
and these are their heroes and you know
you'd think at some point they would say
hmm maybe we're not that good a judge of
character you know maybe we ought to
take another look at a ted cruz maybe
he's not a bad guy you know maybe maybe
picking on mike pence for being true to
his wife isn't really a great you know
look for us
they never do they never listen to us
they're so separated they're so
sequestered by their wealth and their
cultural power more than anything else
their cultural power has sequestered
them that they do not know what they do
not know and that's basically the kind
of stuff that the rest of us are talking
about you and i don't agree on
everything me and ben shapiro don't
agree and michael knows we all have
these big arguments we have a range of
opinions on the right
they've just got this one opinion but
they hear it again and again and again
and they think everything else is evil
so what's the trick i mean you know when
i do my weekly q as on thursday there's
always like 10 questions of the same
variety which is what are the tricks to
wake up my friend how can i bring them
back i can't get them to sit down and
watch a prageru video or dave now you're
too scary for them so i assume you're on
the scary list too andrew like what what
what are the tricks you got any tricks i
mean you were around a lot of these
people
yeah you know
two two things very important one one is
you you've got to speak up this thing
about dropping our voice you know i used
to go into movie studios for meetings
and i'd be sitting out in the waiting
room you know you sit for a few minutes
before they call you in and
almost every time somebody would come up
to me and drop his voice and say i i saw
you on hannity i saw you on beck and i
would always say the same thing why are
you whispering you're in the right
hand
and i understand the fear and i
understand you know we we famously had
this uh supposedly secret organization
the friends of abe out in hollywood
and i kept saying to the leaders you
know we've got to go public and they
wouldn't do it because they didn't want
the working guys to get caught the
gaffers and the guys who were not movie
stars and all this but i just thought if
you don't if you if you act in secret
then you look like you're ashamed and if
you act in secret you look like you're
afraid and so all of us because all of
you know it's not just artists who are
part of the culture it's not just media
people everybody is part of the culture
everybody has a little piece of it like
you know a candle in their hand you have
got to speak up you've got to you've got
to say it politely you don't have to
scream at people you don't have to get
in their faces you don't have to be
donald trump you just politely say you
know i disagree and and if if we don't
start doing that if we let them cow us
and silence us we have no choice chance
and the other side of it also is
right-wingers think that the truth is so
important the facts are so important
that you don't have to be nice about
them that you can scream an ugly truth
in someone's face and paul simon said
you know i want you know i don't want
you to lie to me but i want some
tenderness beneath your honesty and
right winger's got to learn that trick
because
the left are ugly they're mean they call
people names they they're disgusting
they cancel people they bully them if we
don't have a sort of civilized attitude
but
when i say civilized that doesn't mean
keeping your mouth shut it means
speaking bravely and clearly in a polite
way then we're just the same as them
it's we get lost in the crowd so if we
don't develop uh some communication
skills uh and and some courage
you know we'll be lost we'll be swept
away because they own the media you know
it's so funny because i obviously agree
with the sentiment and then there's this
part of me as someone that's you know
sort of new to this thing on the right
let's say that when you see them lie and
lie and lie again and know they're lying
and we know they're lying and everyone
knows the social units in quote and they
just keep going i can somehow see how
decent right-wing people that are
moderates really start sounding like
crazy angry kooks because the years go
by you try to rationalize you try to be
open you try to have conversations they
keep lying things keep getting worse
they're dragging you to hell with them
next thing you know you're screaming on
the radio for four hours a day about
whatever it might be so i'm sympathetic
to even though i get your point i am
sympathetic to the people that it sort
of sound like they're nuts at some level
me too because they also gaslight you so
for 30 years they call you racist they
call you sexist your god stinks your
country stinks your history stinks
everything about you stinks then rush
limbaugh comes on the air and he says
well these feminazis and everybody goes
where is the civility where what where
what has happened to the civility in
this country so they gaslight you but if
you listen one of the things that
happened to me when i came back from
england where i was living i i started
listening to rush just to hear what the
fuss was about and he was so happy and
so funny and so kind of sweet natured uh
with all the stuff that he said that i
thought no wait a minute
that all the stuff i heard is untrue and
i want to listen to what this guy has to
say they called him uncivil and he could
sometimes go off obviously but he was
actually a happy warrior and he was a
wonderfully funny and warm person when
you the one time i talked to him in
person he was kind of shy and sweet
natured and all that was kind of a shock
but still he had he had a knack for that
so you're absolutely right i have total
sympathy for why people do it i know why
they supported donald trump i you know i
told people who were appalled by donald
trump you know think of him as the voice
of people who have been just insulted
for 50 years you know that's what he is
that's why they they came up with him
and you know he had his flaws i think
they really heard him in the end but
they also helped him get where he was
and they made people love him because he
spoke for them but i think we need you
know the thing i liked about this guy in
virginia glenn younkin is he is
civilized he's direct but he says what
he has to say and i think that that's
really the trick i think it's the trick
for all of us because if ordinary people
aren't speaking
we seem like we're afraid and we seem
like we're ashamed yeah and since you
brought up trump i will credit you i've
credited you many times for this but on
election night 2016 and i was not voting
for trump i voted for gary johnson but i
was with you daily wire guys everyone
drinking whiskey and the results came in
everybody was shocked but you said
something to me that really i think lit
a fire under me about the state of the
world which was that look what just
happened in america the thing that
nobody said was gonna happen that
everyone said couldn't happen
it just happened and that is the true
beauty of america that's what we sort of
seem to be forgetting at the moment
you know it's one i have this
conversation especially with
conservatives conservatives have a knack
it's a natural thing and it's one of the
reasons they are conservative is they
can trace any change to disaster so you
know whatever whatever changes it's like
oh yeah well this is going to knock over
that domino and then the wall fall down
and once the ball falls down the savages
come in and we're all dead you know we
do this all the time but just because
having been around so long i've seen a
lot of stuff so i saw new york when it
was a cesspit like it's becoming again
today
and and i i thought this is this is the
end of new york and no giuliani came in
one man came in they called him racist
every single day of his administration
and he turned it into the most beautiful
city in the world the best city in the
world for about 20 years with the help
of uh bloomberg who kept it that way and
now they've just driven it back into the
ground the same was true with the
country the country in the 70s and 80s
was in a terrible state i mean people
were just
so uh unhappy and the gas the lines to
get gasoline just like it is today with
the inflation and all this stuff all
coming back and ronald reagan came in
and said you know what i'm gonna cut
taxes we're gonna change that and we're
gonna and by the way we're gonna win the
cold war and
you know people today say well it wasn't
reagan you know it was it was this it
was that he was the only person who said
that i mean everybody else all the
intellectuals were like what do you mean
and reagan said i mean we we win they
lose and so all of these things can
change in a heartbeat but they don't
change if if people hide they do not
change if people will not you know
make that change i mean my parents
lifelong democrats to the day they died
they voted for giuliani the second time
because they said you know oh the city
was terrible and now it's nice you know
and if we don't have at least that much
common sense uh it's hard to make those
change but it's true as long as we still
have an operational democracy uh and and
we can get the word out and facebook and
twitter and all these people are not
censoring us completely um
you'd be shocked at what can happen so i
want to talk to you a little bit about
where faith
falls into this because you have a
really interesting we've discussed it a
couple of times publicly a really
interesting journey of faith for
yourself personally but i think it also
does frame a lot of your politics and
i've sort of come to the conclusion that
in many ways my frustration with the
last sort of sane liberals is that
they've disconnected everything from
faith thus they end up in this constant
political fight trying to find meaning
in something that can offer no meaning
and i do find that very different than
conservatives who don't find
uh their salvation in politics i i don't
think that politics is everything or
that the culture war is everything or
that the here and now is everything and
i think the the sort of last libs they
kind of do i think jordan peterson was
really trying to
move that for them and i don't know that
it quite got there yet um yeah take that
away take there's the statement
i mean i love jordan i know you love
jordan you know i think he he gets
caught sometimes in what i call the
reason trap you know their reason is a
wonderful thing it is a wonderful way of
figuring out the reasonable part of the
world but there is a part of the world
that's extraordinarily important and
goes beyond that which is the inner
human experience the inner experience of
just being here which is
reason emotion love you know all the all
the what the things that make life
worthwhile you know that actually work
and it's in that place where you start
to sense after a while that oh you know
it's not it's not that i can prove
here's the leap of faith for me i can't
prove that it's better to give a beggar
bread than to torture a child to death
for fun i can't prove that you can't
prove it there's no place of reason
where you can say gee if you enjoy
torturing a child to death why not do it
but you know
you know the same way that you know that
your father should be just the same way
that you know that your mother should be
tender you know that it is better to do
one thing than it is to do another that
is already supernatural in the sense
that physical actions natural actions
have a meaning above themselves that's a
supernatural thing literally when i say
supernatural i mean literally above
nature
and and if there is and if there is
something that is better than something
else then there is something toward
which it tends there is a
an ultimate good
you know something that is the measure
of all good a sovereign good
and if there's a sovereign good it has
to be a consciousness because only
conscious
free consciousness can choose good a
hurricane is neither good or evil it may
do bad things but it's not doing them
for moral reasons so
it makes sense if we believe if we take
it's not even a leap of faith it's kind
of a little hop of faith you know where
you just say if we believe that some
things are good and some things are not
as good
uh that we have to invest in that and
once you do once you do the whole thing
starts to make sense suddenly you say
like oh i just had i just had to affirm
what i believe what i knew was true and
i always tell people don't believe what
you don't believe so if somebody
somebody says to me you know well rachel
levine is really a woman i think like
yeah you don't you don't believe that i
don't believe that you know ben shapiro
can put on a cowboy hat he's not a
cowboy hat he's not a cowboy he's not a
cowboy the only difference is ben will
tell you that yeah but so you you know
rachel levine is not a woman so why say
it what what is the benefit you're
getting from believing something you
don't believe
no one believes no one believes that
that morality is relative
no one believes it
you believe it until somebody
punches your kid then you know that no
you know there are certain things that
are moral
and and once you have a worldview that
makes sense
you you kind of relax into the fact that
there is something beyond yourself and
something beyond this petty fight that
we're in and it makes it easier to kind
of love your neighbor a little bit you
know and the joy that comes with that is
intense it is an amazing thing simply to
make sense simply to live in life and
say like yeah that makes sense and this
doesn't make sense because you have a
standard by which to judge it um
for me
the
it it became christianity at first
because i thought all my values are
coming out of this book
but now i sort of see that christianity
is the
it's the faith of the the word that what
we are that what you and i are is we are
of kind of language
it's not like we're a body with a soul
inside like casper the friendly ghost is
floating around and inside you know
inside dave there's the real day of this
invisible dave it's not that at all it's
that you are a word that speaks dave and
that that dave is an idea in the mind of
god as it were you know and so and and
that once you understand that then
everything that you do becomes kind of
beautiful it all becomes a work of art
if i if i give a beg of bread i'm not
just i'm not just giving a beggar bread
i'm actually doing something good you
know in this supernatural realm it's
incredibly liberating it is an
incredibly liberating uh joyful way to
live when i say joy i don't mean you
walk around happy all the time that
would be crazy what i mean is you live
life with a new gusto because just like
when you watch a movie and there's a sad
scene in the movie and you're crying and
you still love the movie you know and
and life kind of becomes like that you
started because you start to see it has
a meaning beyond itself and so even when
you're tense and things are going badly
and even when you're grieving you
understand that there is this beauty to
it this beauty of creation that's going
on all the time and it's the creation of
you it's creation of your soul becoming
more and more what it's supposed to be
so
yes i i to go back to what you said i
just totally agree that when i see these
guys telling me that oh you know if only
everybody will agree i'm a woman when
i'm a man if only everybody will agree
that uh you know
it's
i'm you only hate me because i'm black
even though i'm holding you up with a
gun you know if only everybody will
agree to
support the lie that gives me
self-respect that lie will become the
truth you know you're sad for them but
you're not even tempted to pretend to
agree
and and that's just liberating it's it's
freeing so so how do we connect some of
what you just said right there to
politics because as you were saying it i
was thinking man you know and i thought
this many times when i was on tour with
jordan that that rough message basically
is what we have to get across to people
to live more flourishing lives and yet
we're arguing about you know 3.5
trillion equals zero and boys or girls
and all of those things like we're not
even doing we're not even doing like a
semi-good job of connecting like meaning
to politics and that seems to me to be
the the biggest problem right now
man i can't i could not agree with you
more and i think you know the left does
do this they just do it for bad ideas
you know the left does make a moral
we're always sitting around with a
pointer saying you'll make much more
money and this like this ein rand
mentality where we think money is
everything is so untrue and it's left
our the people who want to follow us
empty and and wandering and the left
comes along and says no it's right it's
good to believe these stupid things that
we're telling you
to me
the the connection with politics and
there's no i i don't believe there's a
cr there's christian politics i believe
that christian person can be in a in a
range of politics as long as he's not
oppressive and and dishonest and evil uh
he can have a range of politics but to
me at the core of christianity something
i call the the great speculation and the
great speculation is this that your
inner life is as important to you as
mine is to me that's the great
speculation and that's true whether
you're a garbage man whether you're a
homemaker whether you're a dancer singer
whatever you are my the speculation is
that your inner life is as important to
you and as real to you uh and as um
urgent to you as mine is to me and once
you come to that
once you take that guess
first of all you begin to see that it's
true you begin to realize that people
have a right to be left alone they have
a right to live out the meaning of their
lives you know and
and when they when they do that when you
commit to that then you want them to be
free and when you want them to be free
you start to think what are the
conditions of freedom you know obviously
some of the conditions of freedom are
you know have to do with morality you
can't murder people you can't steal from
people you can't uh defraud them you
can't lie about them these are those are
the ten commandments that's where they
come in you know these are these are
things that these are rules that are not
made so you'll be a nice guy you know
like don't do that or we'll punish you
that's not why they're made they're made
to liberate you so that you can be free
uh every one of the founders john adams
said it best but every one of the
founders said the this is a constitution
for a moral and religious people not
just moral but moral and religious
people and the reason for that is you
start to understand that the other guy's
freedom is as important to him
you know as yours is
sometimes i hear people talking and
they'll say well
you know
for instance black lives matter black
lives matter has cost thousands of black
lives it's gotten thousands of black
people killed their attacks on the
police have made the black neighborhoods
more unsafe children are being shot by
random gunman it's a nightmare what
they've done and yet they continue to do
it because they have an idea that it's
good
if for a moment
it occurred to them that these
actual black lives that they are ending
with their policies are just as
important to the people who have them as
their life is to them maybe their
policies would start to seem less
important to them and without religion
without that great speculation which is
a religious idea the idea that your your
neighbor is as worthy of love as you are
um without that
speculation it's so easy to get involved
in your ideas and
the goodness you know oh yes we must
bring justice and therefore we're going
to kill anybody who gets in our way
which is part of mar you know that's
another part of karl marx he basically
said yes terror and killing is fine as
long as you get to the place you have to
get so do you think then to that end
that people are believers whether they
believe it or not i think that's an idea
that jordan's been talking a lot about
lately and i've sort of come to that
conclusion that you end up saying no no
i'm purely secular i just believe in
this and we can just order society this
way but that in and of itself is a type
of belief that's then driving your
decisions
right because this is this is the power
of narrative there's another thing the
left knows about more than us you know
it's like we live in a time
when
it's it's uncouth to say
well you know let's let's see what god's
will let's consult god let's see what
god's will is let's see if this is a a
demonic path we're saying we don't say
those things anymore and there's and
there's a good reason for it but that
good reason has become outdated the good
reason is science you know
when lightning used to strike they used
to think that demons were sending the
lightning so they would ring the church
bells to chase the lightning away that
meant the monk had to climb up to the
highest part of the church and ring the
bell and of course he'd be hit by
lightning and killed right and and when
benjamin franklin put a lightning rod on
top of a steeple it was much safer but
it also was kind of a symbol of a
materialistic philosophy that was going
to replace this spiritual philosophy and
now it's actually called the science as
if it were the wizard of oz you know
it's like because they come and worship
the science
for a while it made sense for people to
say
oh all of our speculations about
demons and about supernatural and all
these words that we don't like to use
anymore we're all wrong but that's not
true anymore science has now progressed
to a point where we see it's not
actually as mechanical as we thought
it's going to be it's kind of weird and
it shouldn't be here it looks by logic
by logic it like life shouldn't be here
creation shouldn't be here we we
shouldn't be able to understand creation
and all those things are true and so
it's time we stopped doing that because
you're i think you're absolutely right
people believe whether they want to
believe or not and it's one of the
reasons that when you let go of that
belief people become evil you know they
they start to teach children to be uh
you know willing victims of pedophilia
they start to teach you about race those
are wicked things to do that's you know
these are wicked things to do because
they've let go of that sovereign good
that is the living god and
in a way if you listen to the way we
talk
we don't even say i was happy anymore we
say i had an adrenaline rush uh we we
use these materialist terms all the time
we don't say oh that's that's
right because it's obviously
right we always have these kind of
evolutionary explanations and you know
we ask or some it's game theory and also
none of which makes any sense by the way
but leave that be that as it may we eat
we're all materialists and so
but and yet we know we don't live in a
materialist world we sense it we feel it
we're born with the knowledge of it uh
like i said there's no evolutionary
reason why we should know our fathers
should be just you know but why why do
we expect our fathers to be just and yet
when they are not just we know they have
failed at some essential task so we all
know it but we have gotten caught up in
this narrative this materialist
narrative that i think is out of date i
just think i think people are living in
the in the 20th century
really and in the 21st century
a lot of scientific
paths have shown that they can't explain
this without a consciousness coming
first the only thing they have to admit
is that consciousness comes before
matter and and i think that's that's an
obvious truth you're saying i shouldn't
light my anthony fouchy candle every
night before bed is that what you're
telling me he's not some sort of saint
that man the highest people if you just
want to watch him burn and melt
i can understand why you might want to
just watch him melt you know and say
that's for the dogs
what does it also what does that tell
you though about the psychiatr the
psychological makeup i suppose of groups
where it's like we see these people that
get so
much wrong consistently and now we have
the video footage to prove it fauci
saying one thing about masks publicly
another thing to his friend about oh no
you can go on vacation and don't worry
about mass because you'll touch your
face more or the vaccines mean we're
going to open up now they don't really
work and you still can transmit
everybody knows the a million examples
that i can use here but but a certain
percentage of people keep going to it
they keep going oh well i forgot i don't
like is it a memory issue is it like
what is it what is it about humans
you know there's a line in dostoevsky
and i can't quote it from memory but the
line is something like
when you make people free when you set
people free their first order of
business is to find something to bow
down to
i think you know we're made to love god
we are made to bow down to god and i
think that um you know
after a while after you lived the
religious life for a while you start to
realize that all your attachments to
things and to p and to people are
pathways to god you know they're not
they're they're symbolic of the love of
god your love for your father's love of
god your love for your mother is the
love of the feminine side of god all
these things that you're looking for
that people fail you in uh are because
they cannot be the perfect thing you're
looking for beyond them and once you
attach yourself to that perfect thing
beyond them it becomes so much easier to
love the imperfect people with their
flaws uh and forgive them for the the
ways they can't be what they can never
be uh and and so you know guys like
fauci are there
because people are just desperate for
that thing and no one will give it to
him and by the way when i when i talk
about this and i talk about being
religious i think our churches have
failed us
utterly you know almost all of our
churches have failed us utterly so don't
think that i'm saying oh yeah you've got
to go down and follow that priest i mean
personally i think we should start i'm
lucky i found a great new church that i
love but
personally i think a lot of people
should just start to gather together in
their homes and start from the beginning
because our churches have really
abandoned the plot so so linking some of
this stuff together i just spoke a
couple weeks ago at the national
conservatism conference and teal spoken
ted cruz and jd vance it was a really
great sort of powerhouse event and what
what they were really trying to do there
is figure out how conservatism
in many ways can link back to all the
stuff we're talking about here and link
back to belief but then will there be
room for the outsiders for the people
that are not religious or for the gay
people and there was a very uh i think
the panel of the entire thing was me and
douglas murray we both happen to be gay
speaking with sora bamari who of course
i'm sure you know uh catholic uh thinker
and author and uh yoram hazoni orthodox
jew trying to figure out can this thing
fit can we fit this thing together now
i'm curious because you're talking about
faith in all of this stuff your son
spencer who's a good friend of mine who
i think is like one of the all-stars of
like the future conservative movement um
he happens to be gay it does not matter
to me uh but as you're talking about
this as a father and then as a
political communicator how do you piece
all of this stuff together i know you
you guys have discussed it publicly once
or twice but yeah yeah no and and you
know my opinion on this has never
changed you know
my father explained this to me once when
we went to a party when i was a little
kid and i saw a gay couple and he
explained it to me and then in those
days saying that this was a
psychological disorder was the liberal
point of view that was the accepting
point of view and and that's what he
said to me and i remember shrugging
saying they're not hurting anybody
and and i still feel that way but i but
actually i i feel that
um god is a lot more hilarious and
creative than we think he is and a lot
of the kind of um
you know pinched mean you know like i
you you have to do what i tell you to do
is not really in the gospels uh and i i
know people get so ticked at me when i
say this but it really isn't and and
there's a much greater sense of like
abundance of of beauty and abundance of
creation i i think we need it it is it
helps political people to talk about a
vertical
world of good and evil
but in fact there is good and evil there
is such a thing as good and evil and
there is that vertical axis but there's
also a horizontal axis of
centrality and outwardness and i i for
instance i'm an artist i've lived my
life as a novelist and artist i'm not at
the center i you know if your garbage
man disappeared you would miss him way
way way before you missed me i'm here to
serve him i'm here to entertain him to
beautify his life to beautify the life
of ordinary people or central people i
should call them because they're not
ordinary but but central people
and and i feel this way about sexuality
too i think the center of human life is
a man and a woman having children i
think if without that you know forgive
me but without that you don't have a a
world you don't have the that central
kind of um polarity yeah i get it
i don't disagree i don't disagree right
but just because something is not at
that center doesn't mean it's not
beautiful and it doesn't mean it's not
part of creation and this is one of the
things i mean you look around one of the
things about spencer is i knew when he
was three year old old i started
thinking ah you know
this kid could very well be gay and you
know i'm i'm going to teach him to be a
man because i think he should be a man
and i hope i did and i think i i
actually believe he's a wonderful man
he's a terrific man but that was who he
was and that was clearly who he had been
born to be and so i think that like a
little bit of just you know
i really do believe that jesus wants us
to blow the hinges off the doors of our
hearts you know just like
okay you know are you hurting anybody
are you preaching evil are you polluting
us are you corrupting us or are you
living in love and and going forward
with whatever you know
you have problems i have problems all
god's children got problems you know
that's that's really the thing that
unites us and so i think if we could
remember as conservatives that there is
this horizontal axis and and we have a
right to prioritize
mommy and daddy families we have a right
to say yes that's the center we need
them just like we have a right to
prioritize uh working people people who
do certain things doctors people who do
certain things that are essential to
human life but that does not mean we
should not live in love and appreciate
the beauty of other kinds of of things
that are not central like art like art
again you know if the great violinist
disappears
you're going to miss your your carpenter
you're going to miss you're going to
miss the lady who was cleaning your
house before you missed the great
violinist he's not at the center of
things but he's beautiful he's he makes
life worth living you know and i just i
i that is the attitude that i really do
have
that's not a put on it there's not a
philosophy that's the way i actually
feel you know i feel that life is a lot
more beautiful when you live that way
and it makes evil putrid you know when
you see how beautiful most people are
really and most relationships are and
then when somebody comes along and says
oh you know you should judge that person
by the color of the skin
there's like a rank smell
and so we we need to i think
conservatives need to live a little bit
and you know what the funny thing is
they've
you know as spencer is engaged to josh
this wonderful guy and he had a house
party yeah so i go to the house party
and
there's you know crazy gay people coming
in there's josh's relatives who are all
these kind of down-home americans from
the midwest and then there's all the
daily wire guys or all these you know
kind of
cigar smoking guy and they're all
right-wing republicans
every one of them had like a right-wing
republican and i just thought you know
we live like this why shouldn't we think
like this why you know don't believe
what you don't believe if we love some
of these people who are there
believe in a philosophical conversation
that gay marriage is the end of western
civilization as we know it but they were
there why because they love spencer they
love josh they they want them to be
happy i think like well why not why not
make that your philosophy you know why
not make the love put the love at the
center of your philosophy and stop
sitting around in your head with ideas
that you know may sound good and may fit
together but actually you're not
expressing that other part of yourself
well that's the funny part because it's
always the anonymous twitter and youtube
commentators telling me how much you
scary conservatives hate me meanwhile
we're breaking bread together and having
a hell of a time and they're the ones in
the name of tolerance and diversity
telling me how much you hate me it's
quite extraordinary you kind of got to
give it credit you know
[Laughter]
yes they're very good no they're very
good at what they do and to be fair they
own so much communication territory it's
a little easier for them than it is for
us we're always kind of struggling to
get our voices heard yeah so as long as
we're talking about art
i've got your new book here and you know
people people in our world in the
political world i don't think everyone
knows that you've been a novelist for
decades at this point
you've how many books how many books
have you written
it's over 30. uh so yeah i lost track
but i mean that's
someone that just finished my second i
don't know how you've possibly written
30 it's pretty exciting and you're
writing novels also so i mean like this
is this is heavy duty stuff uh you write
a lot of mysteries um how did you get
interested in all of this and does some
of the stuff that stuff that you bring
to the novels does that move into the
way you approach politics and and
culture and all that yeah yeah i mean a
novel comes out of you it's a vision you
know and uh and i i loved you know when
i was a kid i didn't really have any
male role models and i was desperate to
find them and i found them in writers
and and most of them were tough guy
writers guys like ernest hemingway but
essentially the ones that i really loved
uh were the mystery the tough guy
mystery writers so docile hammett and
especially raymond chandler with his
kind of knight like you know uh hero who
he he said down these mean streets a man
must go who is not himself mean and
that's where we get the phrase down
these mean streets and and i just love
that idea that the world was corrupt but
you were gonna walk through it just like
this you know just with your eyes on the
right and you were going to do that
right now as a little kid i just thought
that's who i want to be and so those
were the books that kind of inspired me
and as i became a writer i kind of lost
the track for a while in my uh you know
troubled youth but when i
straightened my head out i kind of came
back to that and i i
i consider myself uh you know as good as
any mystery writer alive and uh and and
if i may plug the book yeah
buy this book we'll both hold the book
at the exact same yes yes because i i
will tell you i i had this book in my
mind for i had the last scene in this
book in my mind for 25 years right and i
could not i could not build the story to
get to that last scene
and
you know and i love christmas and i
always wanted to write a christmas story
and i always thought the problem with
chris most christmas stories are bad you
know really only a christmas carol it's
a wonderful life are good christmas
stories and and the reason most of them
are bad is they're about you finding
something that you want finding love or
finding a home or finding mom and dad or
whatever but christmas is actually about
sacrifice and about change it's about uh
with what in the bible they call
metanoia which is turning around and and
giving something away you know giving
something that you love away in order to
be free and so i i wanted to write that
story and i had the scene in my mind and
i couldn't build a story that got
honestly to that scene so my friend otto
pensler who is the great america he's
one of the he is the greatest american
mystery editor
and we were in the pandemic and he was
locked down in the middle of nowhere he
was locked down in connecticut uh and he
called me up and we were having these
conversations and you know i was kind of
keeping him company and he said you know
when are you going to write a christmas
book
and i said you know
i said would you publish it and he said
oh yeah i'll publish a christmas book
so i thought i gotta figure that this
book out and i took two long walks and
at the end of the long walk this little
bell went off and i thought that's
that's the story and it came out i'm so
happy with the way it came out uh it's
been it was it was number 12 on audible
uh and it was number 30 on amazon and
the reviews have just been ecstatic i
mean people are just like on the site
not people i know they're just
raving about it and i i have to say i
know i'm i don't want to oversell it but
i have to say this
we need we need quality art yes on our
side we need stories yeah yes because we
have so much right wing can't and so
much kind of thundering
uh political propaganda and not enough
like just good stories that are imbued
with our view of life which is the kind
of view of life that you and i have just
been talking about through this whole
interview and uh and i i will stand by
this book i i do not believe anyone is
going to read this book and say wow i
got ripped off i think you're going to
read this book and just it's a really
good christmas story well here's my
commitment to you i only got the book
yesterday so i have not read it yet but
i'm hopping on a plane tomorrow tomorrow
two days to go to nashville and i'm
going to have dinner with your son and i
do most of my reading on the plane so i
will i will start the book i'm curious
so you know as someone that's only
written or has only written two
non-fiction books when you're writing a
mystery do you have a freaking big white
board in front of you really plotting
all the twists and turns or are you just
kind of figuring you like know where
you're going at the end and you just
figure it out as you go
no there are some re there are some
writers uh who actually ruth rendell was
one of them actually right off the top
of their heads i outline everything and
sometimes the outline changes along the
way
uh you know when i see that a character
won't do
what i wanted him to do i have to change
the plot to accommodate the character
but if i if i know where i'm going
then i get the joy of writing i hate
outlining by the way and it takes me
weeks to do it and it's just uh dull
it's the only part of my job i i really
find dull but then i'm free to just
write the book and create it and that's
what i really want to be doing so it's
it's much easier that way it always
amazes me the one thing about writers
who don't outline is they they tend to
write the same two or three books over
and over again and ruth rendell is a
wonderful writer but after you've read i
don't know five of her books you've kind
of read her books and like um
i i don't mean to knock her because she
is some of her books are just wonderful
especially her barbara wine books but
but i find if i outline i can say oh
i've done this before and throw it away
and do something fresh and new you know
and that's really been helpful to me and
um i like doing it that way if you read
this if you do read it on the plane and
i trust you i believe you have an honest
face
but but i hope you will say something on
online if you like it
i will i promise you you will get if
it's good you will get the dave reuben
comment somewhere because
for some reason for some reason people
believe what you say so
i'm i'm wondering about it myself
listen before i let you go what anything
else on your mind i kind of didn't want
to do too much of the day-to-day
politics this is exactly what i wanted
to do with you uh because i feel like
everyone's just going nuts with politics
and covet and everything else is there
anything else that's just sort of been
thinking you know you moved life seems
pretty good you got a new book out you
seem happy anything else
you know
it is it's a wonderful time for me and
i'm very grateful uh to have come this
far and actually be doing what i'm doing
and you know loving the people around me
and loving the things that i'm doing
it's really it really is great
and yeah the only thing i would say is i
would just reiterate what i said before
you know that like
we must we ha we cannot be afraid almost
everything the left does is geared
toward making us afraid you know wear a
mask get a vaccine wear two masks wear
six masks you know butcher put a mask on
your children give your children a
vaccine everything is about being afraid
and not only that but they've made fear
of virtue uh what do you mean you're not
afraid of you know climate change are
you a denier you must be a denier you
know everything is about fear and the
reason for that you know c.s lewis the
great christian apologist who wrote
about this he said that you know
he said that the devil wants you to be
afraid because fear courage is the
centerpiece of all virtue you cannot be
virtuous without courage and this is a
moment
i won't lie this is one of the worst
moments in american culture i have ever
seen our art stinks our music stinks our
movie stinks our tvs things most except
for mine many of our novels think but
but and i think the reason for that is
we have gutted our belief system of
everything worthwhile and so people
can't create art
if
if we are not afraid we will pass
through this into a better time there is
simply no question if we're afraid and
if we surrender and if we say yes sir no
okay you know i won't say anything if
you
please don't call me racist if we keep
apologizing like so much of these
canceled fools they cancel you for
something and they say oh i'm so sorry i
want to be a better person and then they
just devour you you know it's like blood
in the water
i i am actually very hopeful i think we
have come to the end of something and
it's the end of the post-war era it's
the end of a post-war order we need new
ideas and i think there are people out
there who are coming spencer one of them
coming along with new ideas new ways of
thinking about things and uh and i'm
actually very hopeful but we have to
start with the courage of all those
people i was talking about who are
central they have to have courage it
can't just be the outlying heroes it's
got to be the people at the center who
start to say you know what we're going
to speak the truth even if you uh
torment us
clavin you finish an interview like you
know where it's going just like a fine
novelist would i look forward to you
having whiskey and me having tequila in
person
one of these days
probably not this town
you got to get out of there and i i
can't wait to see you i always one thing
i hate about the media is that i only
see my friends on camera
the book is when christmas comes i'm
going to read it and i you know what i'm
going to do i'm going to read it and
whether i love it or hate it or
somewhere between i will send you my
comment before i post it so so that you
can make your argument if i don't like
it you can you know push back if i like
it too much i know you wouldn't want
people to think that i'm like you know
doing you a favor here so we'll we'll
figure it out
i know you i'll know i know you'll tell
the truth good seeing you my friend
it's great to see you there if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell